Guyane française, en plein cœur de l'Amazonie.
Perdu en pleine jungle,
Le centre d'entraînement de la forêt équatoriale, le CEFE.
Ici, 34 militaires triés sur le volet,
Commencent l'un des stages les plus éprouvants,
De l'armée française.
Pendant un mois,
Ces militaires confirmés vont apprendre à maîtriser,
Toutes les techniques de la survie en milieu hostile.
Pour tous ces hommes, leur nouveau patron,
Le capitaine Samuel.
C'est sa première année ici.
De l'Afghanistan au Mali,
En passant par la Côte d'Ivoire,
L'officier a servi sur tous les champs de bataille.
Organisé par la Légion étrangère,
Ce stage est pour la première fois,
Ouvert à tous les corps de l'armée française.
Peu importe le grade et le régiment,
À la Légion, on est là pour en baver.
Je ne sais pas comment on vous l'a vendu,
Mais si vous êtes au CEFE et ici
il n'y a pas de stage vacances,
Il n'y a pas de stage où on avance tranquillement.
Où l'instruction, se fait tranquillement,
Et le soir on dort en alvéole.
L'abandon n'est pas possible,
en aucun cas vous arrivez dans mon bureau le soir,
Pour me dire : "C'est bon, j'en ai ma claque, j'arrête !"
Et ma copine, je lui donne un coup de téléphone,
Dans 1h, elle est à l'entrée pour me récupérer en voiture.
Ça, c'est négatif !
Les soldats n'ont aucune idée de ce qui les attend.
Une seule certitude,
Ils vont devoir obéir nuit et jour et au pas de course.
À 7000 km de Paris, l'Amazonie française.
La collectivité territoriale de Guyane,
Recouverte à 94% de jungle.
Dans cet enfer vert, pendant 4 semaines,
Les épreuves vont s'enchaîner à un rythme effréné,
Avec un encadrement qui ne laisse rien passer.
Ferme ta gueule et avance !
Tu vas souffrir, on est bien d'accord !
Commence pas à lever ta tête ! Bouge pas là !
Assis là-bas, personne debout !
Au fil du stage, les corps vont souffrir.
Parmi les victimes, Emilio, il vient du Chili.
Heureusement qu'il a un peu de mental,
Parce que là, Ça va lui faire mal,
Pendant quelques jours.
Les gars je n'arrive plus à respirer, bande de **** !
Mais pas question d'abandonner au premier coup dur.
Les légionnaires comme le Serbe, Nikos, ne lâchent rien.
Le caporal Pierre va lui aussi au bout de ses limites.
Une jungle et un fleuve de tous les dangers.
Il ne comprend pas comme ça, il va comprendre mouillé.
Donc personne debout dans cette putain de pirogue !
Ici cailloux, putain !
Un stage commando où tout se mérite,
À commencer par la nourriture.
La consigne c'est de ne pas monter,
De ne pas toucher la gamelle, de ne pas manger.
De la viande de caïmans pour les heureux élus.
Manger ici, une obsession.
Le ventre vide livré à lui même.
Le caporal Sam s'en remet à son fusil.
Moi qui croyais qu'on n'allait pas bouffer !
Le stage forêt de la Légion,
Un calvaire avec un seul enjeu,
Franchir chaque obstacle pour décrocher le précieux sésame,
Le brevet d'instructeur forêt.
Ce qui se fait de mieux dans la Légion.
La fatigue, la faim, les blessures,
Sur les 34 candidats au départ,
Combien seront-ils à l'arrivée ?
Le stage commence par une épreuve
de natation un peu particulière.
Les stagiaires vont devoir se jeter à l'eau
avec tout leur équipement.
Ils s'apprêtent à embarquer à bord des pirogues de la Légion.
Pour les mener à la baguette, Une équipe de 6 instructeurs,
Dirigée par le sergent chef Thomas.
Après avoir combattu sur tous les fronts,
Il vient d'être muté au CEFE.
Tu as déjà été contrôlé ?
50 tractions légionnaire !
Aucun manquement possible,
Pour chaque écart, une punition.
Une discipline de fer.
Mieux vaut être motivé, comme le légionnaire Jean,
Il vient de l'île Maurice.
Tu veux aller jusqu'au bout ?
Oui, il faut.
Si on est déjà là, il faut aller jusqu'au bout.
Même avec le pied cassé, on va le faire !
D'entrée de jeu,
Les stagiaires sont plongés dans le grand bain.
Sur le fleuve Approuague,
qui borde le centre d'entraînement,
Les soldats se préparent au pire.
En uniforme et rangers aux pieds,
Les militaires doivent nager à contre courant pendant 1h30.
La cause première, avant, des accidents militaires,
C'étaient les morts par noyade en Guyane.
Tous les ans, il y avait des morts par noyade,
En forêt amazonienne,
Pour les militaires, notamment du régiment.
Donc il est indispensable de savoir nager.
Pour les mauvais nageurs, de maîtriser des techniques,
Qui permettent de franchir des coupures
humides en toute sécurité.
Quelques minutes seulement dans l'eau,
Et Jean le Mauricien est déjà en difficulté.
Il faut avancer, si tu n'avances pas,
Les autres restent sur place.
C'est plus fatigant de rester sur place que d'avancer.
Là les mecs se fatiguent pour toi.
Très confiant avant l'épreuve,
le légionnaire n'y arrive pas.
Il n'est pas en mesure de continuer le stage.
Demain, on va nager avec le Famas.
Déjà, il n'arrive pas à gérer.
Avec les Famas, c'est bon il est mort déjà.
Un dernier effort, mais en vain.
Si tu n'es pas capable de le faire,
Ce n'est pas la peine de continuer le stage.
Moi, j'appelle ton capitaine et on te descend à Kourou.
Alors là, tu te reposes une minute
et après tu ne t'accroches plus.
La prochaine fois que tu t'accroches,
c'est dans la pirogue et retour à Kourou.
Nagez les autres. Continuer !
Constat d'échec.
J'ai des crampes aux pieds.
Le légionnaire, Jean,
N'a pas sa place au sein de ce stage d'élite.
Les instructeurs enregistrent leur premier abandon.
Pour le soldat, originaire de l'île Maurice,
Après à peine quelques heures,
L'aventure s'arrête brutalement.
Laisses le tranquille, c'est juste du cinéma.
Que s'est-il passé ?
On nage, on nage, on nage et après
j'ai eu des crampes des 2 côtés.
C'est fatiguant !
Pour le capitaine Samuel,
Soudainement, une nouvelle urgence.
Un deuxième soldat jette l'éponge
et cette fois ci le cas est grave.
L'équipe médicale qui accompagne
chaque épreuve intervient immédiatement.
Ce militaire restera anonyme.
Il fait partie des forces spéciales.
On a quelqu'un qui vient de faire un malaise.
Il était tout pâle, on a préféré
le mettre dans la pirogue, l'embarquer.
Et là, il vient de commencer à cracher du sang.
Donc on ne va pas prendre de risque, on va finir la séance.
On vient de le mettre sous oxygène,
Et Alessio le ramènera à l'infirmerie pour qu'il passe devant l'infirmière.
Pour qu'elle puisse voir d'où ça peut venir.
C'est quoi le problème ?
Il y a du sang mélangé avec du jaune, c'est bizarre.
Infirmière, ici Officier Fouad,
On fait monter légionnaire,
il a fait un début de malaise dans l'eau.
On l'a évacué, il est tout pâle et
il commence à cracher du sang.
Il est sous oxygène. Il va arriver dans 5 à 10 minutes.
Le soldat des forces spéciales est finalement évacuée d'urgence.
Il s'en sortira après une courte hospitalisation.
D'autres soldats avant lui n'ont pas eu cette chance.
Les dangers d'un fleuve et des instructeurs
qui restent vigilants mais
intraitables.
L'hécatombe continue avec un troisième forfait.
Tu continues le stage ou tu abandonnes ?
J'abandonne.
Les stagiaires ne sont déjà plus que 31.
Cette fois ci, c'est un membre de l'armée régulière qui renonce.
Le soldat Alexandre,
Appartient au neuvième régiment d'infanterie de marine.
De retour de mission de combat,
Il n'a eu que 24h pour souffler avant le stage.
Malgré toute sa bonne volonté, ses efforts n'ont pas suffi.
Pour une fois, le sergent chef Thomas
se montre compréhensif.
C'est dommage de perdre quelqu'un comme lui.
Qui était bien motivé, qui avait envie de continuer.
Il rentre chez lui,
Il soigne ses blessures et il revient la prochaine fois.
20 minutes plus tard, c'est la fin de l'épreuve.
31 rescapés tentent, tant bien que mal,
De remonter dans les pirogues.
Ce premier test semblait une formalité.
Les hommes sont déjà exténués,
Alors que la suite du programme,
S'annonce bien plus difficile.
2h de navigation,
Quelques instants de répit,
Avant la suite des épreuves concoctées par les instructeurs.
Allez !
À peine sortie de l'eau,
Direction la redoutable piste Pécari.
Un parcours très physique qui porte le nom
d'un animal d'Amazonie.
En pleine jungle tous les 20 mètres,
Une dizaine d'obstacles à franchir.
Démonstration avec le sergent chef Thomas.
Je pose mes mains à plat sur la table.
Méthode semi athlétique, hop !
Passage en barrage.
Tu descends.
Tu regardes au fond de la piste en soufflant et en expirant ! Et là, je continue
ma course.
Tout à la force des bras, un nouveau défi de taille.
De la sueur et de la boue.
Mais il en faut plus pour impressionner Sam.
Il vient de l'infanterie de marine.
Je n'irais pas jusqu'à dire que c'est facile, pas à ce point.
Mais c'est faisable. Après,
on prend le rythme mais bon ça pique !
Toujours à la manœuvre,
L'instructeur Thomas ouvre la voie et donne les règles du jeu.
Les stagiaires ont 10 minutes maximum
pour l'ensemble du parcours.
L'épreuve est déterminante pour l'obtention du brevet.
Question ?
En place.
Plus de 10 minutes sur cette piste,
C'est moins de la moyenne, donc c'est un échec.
C'est le stage spécial forêt équatoriale,
Donc ça fait partie des critères éliminatoires du stage.
Aujourd'hui, si quelqu'un n'a pas la moyenne,
Il fera le stage, entre guillemets,
Gratuitement, Puisqu'il sait d'ores et déjà
qu'il ne sera pas breveté à la fin.
Gratuitement,
Cela veut dire que pour tous ces hommes,
Il n'y a pas d'erreur possible.
Les militaires n'ont le droit qu'à une seule tentative,
Un échec et c'est l'élimination.
Début d'une course contre la montre.
Les obstacles s'enchaînent.
Le chrono tourne sans que les soldats
et la moindre notion du temps.
Il reste 2 obstacles, c'est les plus faciles.
La fatigue, le bois glissant, la boue,
Rien n'est épargné aux stagiaires
de la Légion étrangère.
À la fin de la piste, chaque soldat doit encore s'annoncer.
La technique s'apprend, ça se travaille,
Tu vas améliorer la prochaine fois.
Même les soldats d'élite,
Terminent la piste à bout de souffle,
Comme le caporal Pierre de l'infanterie de marine.
Il a remporté l'épreuve,
Mais a beaucoup de mal à reprendre sa respiration.
C'est au tour d'un légionnaire d'en terminer.
Recommence.
Encore plus épuisé.
Tu as perdu 10 secondes,
Parce que je t'ai demandé la confirmation de ton numéro,
Et tu ne me répond pas.
Tu n'as pas envie de me répondre ?
Non.
Tu aimes souffrir ?
Oui. Tu vas souffrir, on est bien d'accord.
Se présenter correctement fait partie
du code d'honneur de la Légion.
Silence, ferme ta gueule !
Et seulement quand on vous y autorise.
Cela ne saute pas aux yeux,
Mais le sergent chef Thomas se félicite,
Des résultats obtenus par ses stagiaires.
Le niveau général pour un premier déroulé,
Des pistes Pécari, est satisfaisant.
Pour l'instant, Il y a 3 stagiaires qui ont échoué
sur l'épreuve des pistes.
Sur les 35 stagiaires.
Qui d'entre eux a échoué ?
Aucun des militaires ne le saura avant la fin du stage.
Ils se sont pourtant tous donnés à fond.
Certains ne s'en sont pas sortis indemnes.
C'est le cas d'Emilio, un légionnaire chilien,
Qui s'est blessé à la main.
Tu as quand même réussi.
Oui, j'ai réussi.
Si j'abandonne, c'est l'échec.
Tu es hyper motivé toi ?
Ouais, mais je ne veux pas abandonner.
Je fais des efforts déjà ! Il faut que je tienne.
Emilio souffre et s'inquiète.
C'est la deuxième fois qu'il tente le stage.
Évacué d'urgence l'année dernière,
Il sait qu'il n'aura pas droit à une troisième chance.
Il n'a pas d'autre choix que de continuer le stage,
Avec une main sérieusement abîmée.
L'infirmière, Emanuelle,
Est peu rassurante pour la suite de l'aventure.
C'est compromettant pour la suite ?
En fait, c'est embêtant pour le reste du parcours.
Puisque ça va lui faire mal. Après, c'est aussi embêtant parce qu'on est en
ambiance humide. Du coup, ça risque de s'infecter.
Il va falloir surveiller. Il va falloir qu'il ait un peu de mental !
Parce que là, ça va lui faire mal pendant quelques jours.
Emilio est loin d'être le seul stagiaire blessé.
Un autre légionnaire a des douleurs musculaires.
La première semaine du stage,
C'est la semaine de sélection naturelle.
On a tendance à dire, que c'est la semaine
où les gens sortent de leur confort,
Du quartier. Même s'ils sont habitués à pire,
Ils sont loin d'être habitués à ce genre de activités incessantes.
Et qui demande aussi beaucoup de résistance physique.
Comme d'habitude, on a les premiers
symptômes qui apparaissent.
Avec notamment mal de dos,
Mal de genou et mal de chevilles.
Donc on a beaucoup de personnel
qui commence à être touché,
Par ces petites douleurs.
Les stagiaires quittent la piste Pécari,
pour quelques minutes de répit.
Une rare occasion pour souffler et faire reposer les corps,
Rudement mise à l'épreuve.
Le stage est dur ou pas ?
C'est tout dans la tête !
C'est vrai ?
Tout dans la tête.
C'est pas facile.
Ce n'est facile pour personne.
Non, c'est pas facile. Ce qui me fait tenir,
C'est que je me dis que c'est 4 semaines.
Au bout de 4 semaines, ça s'arrêtera là.
J'en garderai des bons souvenirs.
On rigolera sur ce qui s'est passé,
Sur les erreurs qu'on a fait, sur les réussites,
Tous autour d'une bière et voilà.
C'est la forêt qui nous fatigue.
Ce n'est pas les exercices, c'est la forêt.
C'est la forêt qui nous tue.
Après une journée particulièrement difficile,
Le soleil se couche sur le fleuve Approuague.
Mais pour les stagiaires,
Pas question de dormir tout de suite.
Ils sont levés depuis 5h du matin.
Il est 21h et il faut encore préparer le couchage à la belle étoile.
Les instructeurs leur désignent
chaque soir un nouvel emplacement.
À chacun de préparer son bivouac.
Avant de mettre son bivouac et de dormir tout de suite,
Il faut vérifier au sol qu'il n'y ait rien qui traîne.
Tout ce qui est scorpion et animaux dangereux pour l'humain.
Pareille sur les arbres, vérifiez que l'arbre soit solide.
Donc si l'arbre est pourri,
On a vite fait de se retrouver au sol,
Sans même s'en rendre compte.
En guise de lit, un hamac posé entre deux arbres.
Je pense qu'on dormira jusqu'à la fin dans la forêt.
C'est le but. Ça nous entraîne pour nos futures missions.
C'est très important le produit anti-moustiques.
En pleine jungle, tout est question de survie.
Se protéger des moustiques, improviser un éclairage,
Ou, plus compliqué encore, s'assurer un minimum d'hygiène.
Quitte à tricher avec le règlement pour prendre une douche.
On peut prendre les douches à côté,
Où il y a les tuyaux.
Mais si on se fait choper, c'est pour notre gueule.
C'est bon ?
Discrétion !
La seule source d'eau autorisée pour se laver,
Est le fleuve, À 15 minutes de marche du camp.
D'un commun accord, les stagiaires
décident d'enfreindre la règle,
Et de se doucher dans le camp des instructeurs.
Un écart qui pourrait leur coûter très cher.
La douche aux jets d'eau, c'est vraiment le grand luxe.
Pour ici, c'est plus que du luxe, c'est le paradis.
La douche ici, un simple tuyau d'arrosage.
Un jet d'eau rudimentaire,
Qui fait pourtant le bonheur des stagiaires habitués à bien pire.
En un temps record, ils se lavent et se rasent.
Après 20 minutes sans s'être fait prendre par les instructeurs,
Les soldats regagnent leur bivouac.
Sam peut enfin souffler.
Le bilan qu'il tire de ses premiers jours est plus que mitigé.
Militaire dans l'armée régulière,
Il apprécie peu le commandement rigide de la Légion.
Je pense sincèrement à arrêter des fois quand on voit le rythme,
Mais je m'accroche.
Je m'accroche pour ma femme, pour ma fille,
Pour ma famille et pour moi aussi.
Disons qu'il ne faut pas que j'abandonne,
Que j'ai une structure de moral de temps en temps.
Coups de blues et choc des cultures.
Sam n'est pas préparé aux méthodes de la Légion.
À la Légion, ils ont une façon très particulière
de commander ces hommes.
C'est particulier, il faut le vivre.
Je ne suis là pour critiquer, c'est leur façon de faire.
Comme je dis, Il y a des excellentes personnes
chez les légionnaires,
C'est des mecs au top. Déjà d'une, ils viennent de l'étranger,
Ils viennent se battre pour un pays qui n'est pas le leur.
C'est tout en leur honneur.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Mais après la façon de commander
et de manœuvrer leurs troupes,
C'est pas trop comme la régulière,
C'est pas du tout comme on a l'habitude de travailler.
Quand je commande, je commande
comme je voudrais être commandé.
Et c'est pas du tout comme ça
que je commanderait personnellement.
Mais bon, après c'est leur façon de faire.
Je ne critique pas, mais à leur place je ne ferai pas comme ça.
On ne peut pas prendre d'initiative.
On est obligé d'attendre qu'on nous dise de faire.
Même si on a l'idée bien avant qu'on nous le dise des fois.
Mais on ne peut pas se permettre de prendre l'initiative.
Ça crée des tensions, des problèmes.
On n'est pas là pour réfléchir.
Le problème, c'est que ça se résume qu'à ça.
Porter et courir. Mais c'est pas grave, on fait avec.
Ça fait partie de l'entraînement.
Sixième jour du stage spécialiste forêt.
Ce matin, c'est instruction pirogue.
Ralentis un peu.
Sans maîtrise de ce moyen de transport,
Pas de brevet pour les stagiaires.
Si c'est bon, on y va.
Prends au large et après tu tournes.
Fabrice est guyanais.
Spécialiste de l'Amazonie,
Il connaît la jungle et ses rivières dans ses moindres recoins.
C'est l'un des rares civils sur place,
Engagé par la Légion étrangère.
Restes droit.
Arrêtes de bouger comme ça.
Il prend son rôle très à cœur.
Alors tu foires, enlèves ta main,
Enlèves ta main du bord de la pirogue.
Putain, c'est pas possible. Tu as vu l'autre zigoto tout à l'heure,
a faillit s'arracher les mains avec l'hélice.
Point mort !
C'est pas possible ça !
Tiens ta pagaie là.
On y va.
Dans les méandres de l'Amazonie,
Une mauvaise manipulation de la pirogue peut être fatale.
Neutre, neutre, neutre.
Comment on dit neutre dans ta langue ?
Comme ça tu vas comprendre !
Il n'y a pas "neutre" dans ta langue ?
Éteins le moteur, éteins !
Et toi c'est pas rentré dans ta tête toi.
Je t'ai dit de tenir la pirogue,
je ne t'ai pas dit d'avancer la pirogue.
On dirait que vous comprenez moins
le Français qu'au début du stage.
C'est incroyable ça !
Marche arrière. Regarde, regarde ton pilote.
Fabrice, l'instructeur,
Est intransigeant en matière de sécurité.
Tout écart est sanctionné sans appel.
Une fois que tu vas arriver devant tu sautes de la pirogue.
Sale manière de pencher le moteur.
Allez, marche avant et tu passes tranquillement là-bas.
Assis toi, je ne t'ai pas dit debout.
C'est pas grave.
Pour s'être levé dans la pirogue,
Un stagiaire doit plonger tout habillé dans le fleuve.
J'ai dit personne debout dans ma pirogue.
Moi j'en ai rien à foutre.
C'est pas grave. Si moi j'arrive à voir, toi tu peux le voir assis largement.
Moi, je suis sûr que si je me mets devant assis, je vais le voir.
Il n'y a pas d'excuses à chercher,
Quand je dit assis, c'est assis c'est tout.
C'est bon ou pas ?
O nen se lève pas dans la pirogue,
Parce que moi j'ai perdu un camarade comme ça.
Il est mort à cause de ces conneries là.
Donc personne debout dans cette putain de pirogue.
C'est clair ?
Les autres vous avez compris ?
Je ne me répèterai pas.
Tu as eu un camarade qui a eu un accident ?
Oui, même plusieurs.
Dont un camarade,
qui travaillait avant pour le centre,
Il a eu le malheur de rester assis sur le nez de la pirogue.
Le mec qui pilotait,
a percuté un caillou et il est passé par dessus bord.
Le moteur lui a tapé la nuque.
On l'a retrouvé trois jours plus tard, mort.
J'ai un autre collègue aussi, mais là, c'est autre chose.
Lui, il a percuté un arbre avec sa tête,
Avec 75 chevaux à fond.
Donc on ne roule pas à fond, les gars.
Lui, il a percuté l'arbre et il est tombé dans l'eau.
Il a eu son visage complètement ouvert,
Et dans la position de pilotage qu'il était,
On l'a retrouvé comme ça sous l'eau.
Le choc était tellement puissant,
Qu'il avait toujours la lampe dans la main.
Il n'a pas lâché. Et il était comme ça,
comme s'il était en train de conduire.
Donc on fait attention. La pirogue, c'est dangereux.
On se fait mal très vite.
Ok ? Questions ?
Malgré les coups de gueule à répétition,
Les sermons et les recadrages,
Les quelques jours passés à apprivoiser la pirogue dans cet enfer vert,
Ont permis à Sam de retrouver le moral.
On apprend pas mal de trucs.
C'est une semaine un peu plus calme que les autres.
Ça, c'est clair.
C'est le calme avant la tempête, apparemment.
On verra bien. On est là, on a les pieds dedans.
On va jusqu'au bout.
Le caporal Sam ne s'y trompe pas,
Dans ce stage intensif,
Mieux vaut savourer les journées les plus calmes.
Avant d'affronter la suite du programme de choc,
Les stagiaires apprennent à vivre
dans l'environnement de la forêt,
Le fleuve, pour se nettoyer et laver leur uniforme.
Et dès qu'il est possible,
Reprendre des forces et s'alimenter.
Dans chaque sac une ration de survie pour chaque jour.
Quelqu'un a de l'eau fraîche ?
Le militaire mange des rations de combat sur le terrain.
Là, pour le moment, c'est du lyophilisé
comme on trouve énormément d'eau ici,
Et c'est beaucoup plus pratique pour le sac,
De ne pas transporter d'eau.
Donc là c'est de la lyophilisé.
Là, ici, j'ai le menu numéro 1,
C'est pâtes au thon et petits légumes à la provençale,
Du café, du chocolat, de la soupe,
Une boisson isotonique et un petit paquet de mouchoirs.
Il y a combien de calories par ration ?
Environ 3000 calories à peu près par rations.
Après, on les dépense vite ici, les 3000 calories.
On transpire et tout.
Ça va très vite !
Et ça, on en mange quasiment tout le temps ?
Tout le temps la même chose.
On mélange.
De l'eau, du lait et on déguste.
Dans des moments comme ça,
il faut dire ce qui est, c'est bon.
Ça passe très bien.
Le quotidien pour encore 3 semaines.
Des céréales chocolatées pour Sam.
Un hachis Parmentier revisité par l'armée
pour le légionnaire Igor.
Ça passe.
On n'est pas au resto.
C'est déjà pas mal que ce ne soit pas toujours des pâtes.
Ce jour là,
Loin des exercices physiques éprouvants qui vont vite reprendre,
Place à la théorie.
Le combiné, L'apprentissage du morse.
Pour le brancher, ça ne sert à rien de forcer.
Là, ça ne va pas rentrer. C'est comme avec
les femmes, il faut y aller tout
doucement.
Il faut y aller en douceur, comme on dit.
Donc vous posez, vous tournez.
Le morse,
Un moyen de communication primordial,
Pour les missions isolées en pleine jungle.
Très vite, Les stagiaires vont devoir
s'initier à cet alphabet codé.
Le morse, C'est indispensable, mais c'est difficile.
Les stagiaires ont très peu de temps avant le test.
Donc je vous rassure,
Ce n'est pas en 20 ou 30 minutes
que vous allez apprendre le morse.
Mais je veux juste vous montrer la base.
C'est pas notre truc, c'est sûr.
Je sais pas.
Moi je ne suis pas dedans.
À peine le temps de se frotter à cette nouvelle méthode,
Et c'est déjà le test.
Une épreuve qui, comme les autres,
Va compter dans l'évaluation finale du stage de la Légion.
Le capitaine Samuel, donne ses dernières instructions.
Vous transmettez et envoyez un message de 4 mots,
À peu près 15 lettres. C'est pas compliqué.
Quand il a fini,
Vous notez "trait, point, point, trait" ainsi de suite.
Et à la fin, vous aurez le temps de chercher la correspondance.
Et quand vous avez le message, vous me l'apportez.
Le message est bon, vous allez dormir.
Le message n'est pas bon, on recommence.
Et ainsi de suite. Donc il y en a, dans dix minutes ils sont au lit.
Et d'autres dans 2h seront encore là.
Allez, silence total !
C'est parti !
Pour les soldats, un casse tête commence.
Le premier à déchiffrer le message,
C'est le caporal chef Sam.
Ce n'est pas un hasard.
Il est transmetteur radio dans son régiment.
Il peut aller dormir avant tous les autres.
Caporal chef là-bas, dodo !
Pour ceux qui continuent de plancher, le sommeil,
C'est loin d'être gagné.
On ne va pas dormir ce soir !
A mon avis.
Sinon, si on va dormir, ça va être trop tard.
De retour sur les bancs de l'école,
Les stagiaires sont placés sous bonne garde.
Cinq minutes, mettez votre main devant votre feuille,
Comme ça votre camarade ne va pas venir chercher la réponse chez vous.
C'est compliqué !
Pas d'à peu près dans la Légion.
Le message codé doit être déchiffré à la lettre près.
Le légionnaire Nikolaï espérait bien pouvoir aller dormir,
Mais il va devoir revoir sa copie.
Là, il y a une erreur.
Il y a une erreur ici, donc tu restes là et tu cherches.
Silence là-bas.
Après près de 2h d'examen,
Il ne reste plus que deux stagiaires,
Dont le légionnaire Emilio,
Qui s'était blessé à la main et à qui rien n'est épargné.
Je me suis dit, ça,
ça correspond à ça.
C'est bon, c'est bien.
Fin de l'exercice et privilège,
Cette nuit, pour la première fois de l'aventure,
Les stagiaires ne rejoindront pas la forêt.
Ils dormiront dans un semblant de confort.
Une nuit de repos bien mérité avant les épreuves à venir.
Après une semaine de stage,
Pour les volontaires, le supplice est loin d'être terminé.
Le sergent chef Thomas leur présente le nouveau défi.
Avec moi, vous allez voir une technique pour grimper aux arbres,
Rassemblement rapidement,
En forme de secte, en face de l'arbre là-bas !
Objectif de l'épreuve,
Atteindre une gamelle posée à 9 mètres de hauteur,
Sur un arbre.
Et grimper uniquement avec la force des bras.
Un exercice dangereux,
Où toute chute peut être très grave.
Pour motiver les troupes,
Ceux qui parviendront au sommet auront droit à un vrai repas,
Composé de viande fraîche.
Pour les heureux élus, Un barbecue version locale à base de caïmans.
Ceux qui ont monté mangeront en premier.
Avec la liberté de choisir de remplir leur assiette autant qu'ils veulent,
Et les derniers ne ramasseront que les miettes de ce qui restera.
But de l'exercice,
En mission savoir grimper en haut des arbres peut être crucial.
C'est parfois le seul moyen de pouvoir émettre des ondes et communiquer.
Il est légèrement affamé à lui.
Mais aujourd'hui, la gamelle est synonyme d'un bon repas.
Depuis que j'ai commencé ici,
Je suis une boule de feu. Au bout d'un moment, la fatigue s'installe !
Un défi qui, pour certains, comme le caporal Pierre,
Paraît mission impossible.
Je fais 84 kilos, j'en fais pas 76 ou 68.
Au fil de l'épreuve,
La tension devient maximale au vu de l'enjeu.
Depuis une semaine, midi et soir,
Les stagiaires n'ont eu droit qu'aux rations de survie.
Aujourd'hui, à la clé, De quoi améliorer peut être l'ordinaire.
La bouffe mon gars !
J'ai faim, je monte.
Ah oui, juste pour bouffer !
Voilà la consigne c'est :
Pas monter, pas toucher la gamelle, pas manger !
Ça c'est la consigne !
Pas de cerveau, pas de migraine !
C'est maintenant,
Au tour du caporal Pierre.
Affamé, Il entame cette montée avec énergie, sous les encouragements.
Serres bien les pieds, ça commençait à être facile.
Vas-y.
Aller, ne lâche pas.
Ces efforts sont visiblement mal dosés.
Il fatigue vite et fait du surplace.
Les instructeurs lui demandent d'arrêter.
Il échoue à 2 mètres du but.
Plus de force, voilà
ce que ça donne quand on ne travaille pas l'économie.
Quand on commence un truc, soit on va jusqu'au bout,
Soit on entreprend rien du tout.
C'est comme ça que je le vois.
L'échec c'est pas ton truc.
L'échec ce n'est pas pour les mecs à l'armée de toute façon.
Soit on va jusqu'au bout, soit on arrête !
Un contrat, ça se résilie.
Je ne suis pas venu pour la lumière.
Sinon, je reste chez moi, J'aurais dit non pour le stage.
Je serai avec ma femme en train de regarder la télé,
Et ça se passerai bien. Mais bon, j'ai décidé d'être ici,
Donc c'est pour aller jusqu'au bout. Prends celle qui est déjà prête, elle est
plus petite. Prends celle-là.
À la Légion,
L'échec n'est pas une option.
Le nœud en bas.
Et pire encore,
Le capitaine Samuel ne supporte pas,
Tout manque de volonté.
Ce stagiaire va en faire les frais.
Ok.
Il faut au moins essayer !
Là, tu fais un premier essai, tu glisse directement.
C'est bon, j'arrête !
Là les camarades qu'on a laissé faire,
Premier essai on a laissé dégager.
On s'est dégagé parce qu'ils ont essayé.
Toi, tu n'essayes même pas là.
On essaye au moins de monter là haut.
Minimum. Je préfère voir un mec qui passe 10 minutes à faire 1m,
Qu'un mec qui se met dessus, qui glisse et qui arrête tout de suite.
Allez, retourne là-bas.
Le caporal Emilio, lui, a bien compris le message.
Malgré sa blessure,
Il n'hésite pas un instant à tenter l'impossible.
Grimper à l'arbre à l'aide d'une seule main valide.
Ne
lâche pas là.
Malgré les encouragements, pas de miracle,
L'effort est trop rude.
Le caporal Emilio renonce.
Il n'aura pas le droit au festin.
Il rejoint les 14 stagiaires qui n'ont pas relevé le défi.
Ceux qui sont montés à la Pékonia, venez ici devant moi !
Tous les mecs qui ont réussi !
Une colonne par là. Tous ceux qui ont réussi, venez par là !
Avec votre quart à la main et votre assiette de fortune.
Pour ceux qui ont réussi l'épreuve,
L'heure de la récompense tant attendue,
Un festin en pleine jungle.
Pour ses soldats affamés un menu inespéré.
Une feuille de bananier comme assiette.
C'est la ruée sur la viande de caïmans.
Le premier vrai repas que vous mangez en forêt ?
Oui le premier vrai repas !
Jusqu'à maintenant on mangeait des rations.
La jubilation de manger de la vraie viande.
Sous le regard envieux des recalés,
Qui vont devoir se contenter des restes.
Ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils ratent.
La chair de caïman a vite trouvé ses adeptes.
Ça a quel goût le caïman ?
C'est entre le poulet et le poisson.
Le soldat Nikolaï, vient de Serbie.
Sa particularité ?
Un corps couvert de tatouages,
Qui raconte sa vie et son engagement envers la Légion étrangère.
J'ai un chevalier, cela signifie un militaire.
Un chevalier avec les 4 S, signifie Serbie.
Là je suis à la légion. Je reste toute ma vie à la Légion.
Je peux me tatouer, il n'y a pas de problème.
Là, je vais me tatouer jusqu'au bout.
Si son estomac a été bien rempli,
Certaines parties du corps continuent de souffrir,
Comme ses pieds.
J'ai du mal à enlever les Rangers ou quoi ?
J'ai mal ici, aux talons, mais je pense que c'est des ampoules.
Pour Nikos, un béret vert comme lui, peut tout supporter.
À la Légion, les bérets verts ont dit :
"En avant, toujours en avant".
C'est notre mot dans le régiment.
Bah on y va, on finit ce stage.
Il ne faut pas chercher à comprendre.
J'ai mal au pied mais on y va !
C'est le but de la légion.
Dans 3 jours, on va être fatigués !
Mais c'est l'humidité qui nous fatigue.
Après, il faut regarder et penser comme un prédateur.
Il ne faut pas se prendre pour un victime,
Sinon le foret va nous manger.
C'est mieux de se regarder, de se prendre pour un prédateur.
Un prédateur toujours au pas de course,
Au rythme de la légion.
À la tombée de la nuit,
C'est la visite médicale obligatoire pour les stagiaires.
9 jours se sont écoulés depuis le début de cette instruction,
Hors du commun et les dégâts corporels sont nombreux.
Le capitaine Samuel a imposé une visite hebdomadaire.
C'est l'infirmière Emmanuelle qui inspecte les militaires.
Elle est en Guyane pour une mission de 3 mois.
Signe ça gonfle, tu reviens nous voir !
Qu'est-ce que vous regardez ?
Là, on regarde leurs pieds, l'intégrité de leurs pieds.
S'ils n'ont pas d'abrasions dans le dos dû aux sacs.
Et de partout, voir s'il n'y a pas d'infection.
C'est maintenant au tour du légionnaire Emilio.
Ça va ?
Sa main est guérie,
Mais le sort continue de s'acharner sur lui.
L'humidité a rongé ses pieds.
Les infirmiers sont dépassés par la situation.
Le médecin est appelé à la rescousse.
Il lui faut un bain de pieds de potassium,
Pendant 10 minutes.
Ça a commencé quand ça ?
Hier.
En 24h ?
Ça fait depuis hier ?
Oui.
Je sens que c'est ici, c'est là.
Ouais.
Pour le médecin en chef, Émilio met sa santé en danger.
Pour moi, c'est compliqué que tu puisses continuer le stage.
Tu auras d'autres occasions de participer au stage.
C'est la dernière.
Oui, c'est la dernière fois.
Je peux courir !
Oui, mais tu peux courir, bien sûr.
Mais encore une fois, ce n'est pas le fait que tu puisses courir ou pas.
La question, c'est qu'il y a un risque d'infection,
Qui est trop important par rapport à tes blessures au niveau du pied.
Voilà, c'est ça en fait.
Il n'y a pas de médicament miracle.
Surtout que tu vas continuer à être dans un milieu humide.
Tu vas aller dans l'eau, tu vas courir,
Tu vas être en permanence mouillé au niveau des pieds,
Au niveau des jambes et ça ne pourra pas se soigner correctement.
Si on veut que ça se soigne et que ça guérisse,
malheureusement il faut t'extraire du milieu dans lequel tu es.
Je te laisse. Bon courage.
Et puis on en fini les soins.
Émilio encaisse le coup,
Pour la deuxième année consécutive,
Le légionnaire chilien risque de devoir abandonner le stage sur avis médical.
Il n'aura pas de troisième chance, ni ici, ni en métropole.
Son rêve de devenir à son tour instructeur forêt,
S'éloigne subitement.
C'est la deuxième fois que j'essaye de réussir ce stage !
Que s'est-il passé la première fois ?
La première fois, j'ai aussi eu une infection.
Une infection du pied droit.
Si tu rates, tu peux recommencer une troisième fois ?
Non, ce ne sera pas possible une troisième fois.
L'année prochaine je vais rentrer en métropole.
C'est pas possible. C'est la dernière chance ?
Exactement, c'est la dernière fois.
C'est pour ça que j'ai fait un gros effort.
Malgré ma blessure.
A moins d'un miracle,
Emilio va devoir quitter le stage.
Malgré toute sa volonté,
Les épreuves à venir s'annoncent comme au dessus de ses forces.
Dans les jours qui viennent,
Les parcours du combattant vont encore se durcir.
Les soldats vont aussi devoir survivre en autonomie dans la jungle.